Morrison pass to the middle Lowry with
an opportunity trying to slide it home
and shutting the door Isen shot we got a
penalty shot as a captain of the Jets see
what he can do here in the early stages of this
one here comes Lowry scores and the hand to the
air they're still the Rivalry the win just the
guys who are in the Canadian Division and you
hand to the a five hole Jake Allen started to go
across and when you start to go across you've got
to open up a little bit and Adam Lowry perfect
timing slides it through starts to go with the
leg and you can see the opening Montreal Zone
by Peretti Allen playing that puck to an open
gie and now it's Raphael Harvey penard to pass to
the middle the chance it a from Justin [Applause]
Baron do a nice job on the Rush look at this
pass up the middle Baron cutting through and
another five hole goal and you can see RIS
looking around never had a chance to get
set skate Baron just directs it to the net
and and it goes through underneath the arm
I guess that wasn't a five hole goal as much as
underneath the arm 14 hole more than you know a
favorite weekend for the Morgan and Justin
Baron family as shley comes in with speed
he's got a fou along now the pass in front and
a great stop from Jake Allen with the left P now
it's Peretti dishing ahead it's Lowry taking
a look the pass elers finds it and he fires
it Allen trying to BL it he does Duncan Keith
every time he came into town whether it was
with the Blackhawks or the Oilers the Canuck
fans did not forget certain moments just get
etched in your memory second period underway
here between Winnipeg and Montreal the Jets
looking to score on they two Lowry with his
second of the game the goahead goal early on
the score sheet once again appeton his line mates
and for the Winnipeg Jets they like to roll four
lines and seems like each line is becoming
a threat to score here's another opportunity
and a goal again from the same line This Time
Neer Rider and it's 3 to one for Winnipeg ksky
for Montreal losing it and the mnov at peret
exchanging passes mov was in Allen the save
they're still whacking away M again control goes
up top Suzuki pass in front and a go from Shan
[Applause] M and the Canadians are within one
and now the puck stays in and look at how wide
open Monahan is boy oh boy they the jetsu had
been really structured in the penalty kill
there's the Chase and there's Dello coming way
late Monahan all by himself fake shot backand
to Dello Dello to eers a chance for shley he's
got coner with him and a great block but eers
trying to capitalize right after the Canadians got
another goal and you can see Nikolai eer trying to
go five pole he's got some time Jack up to Monahan
gallager in front TI and a great stop from brah an
opportunity for Harris as he fires it's near the
net BR the pat stop right in front of the goal
line Mark shley and his linemates leaning on
Lowry's line to really get everything going
for the Jets as shle is hearing it from the
Montreal fans as eers takes a look cross ice
it hops over Kyle Conor stick and taking
off with it is Harvey Berard short-handed
opportunity off the iron what a blistering
shot that was quickly back on the attack
elers cuts to the middle backhand pass to
Conor he circles and stops feeds it ahead
gets it back Conor to eers from the point back
to Conor Conor looks it's NE Rider now eers his
passes intercept CED and it's Kaden G moving up
with speed he enters the Zone a pass over arm
[Music] SC but not the post and then the Canadians
and look at go boy oh boy that's a good play but
that's what happens and you can see eers is
the defenseman look at eers boy oh boy that's
what happens when you have a forward trying to
play defense and eers turned right to the boards
and that gives gou the the Lane right up the
middle and there's another five hole goal as our
Mia the mes to gari he's in alone and Jake Allen
up to the task Rasmus kapari looking for some
room as Schmidt has it again to sber back to SMI
what timer and a terrific save from chick Allen
pass in Pat out and here come the jets shley fires
and right on Q Jake Allen with another good stop
collected by Kyle Conor and it's shley moving
in two on one shley keeps shoots Allen another
stop dishing back it's nikov stick
handling through neutralized coming
at with speed the missov shoots Allen
got enough and steered that pack out
of play here's the [Applause] save new
hook makes a move to get past shle new
hook weight shoots Russ SW the save the
puck was available in front of the net
but that's going to do it in overtime and
we're going to head to the shootout here in
[Applause] Montreal Suzuki coming in wide
Dees and scores ohy boy if you don't get
the Poke check out and Suzuki makes that
move you're dead he waited and SW doesn't
use the Poke check gets in so close and
you can see no poke check mark sheley's
turn boy can you hear it now shley
moving in slows it down shoots stopped by
Allen and you can see shley almost second
guessing himself comes in comes in and
tries to get it over the pad under the
blocker but doesn't get it high in enough
Cole Coffield he's next up Coffield coming
in wide as well and it's in the glove of
bruss Monahan going for the victory Monahan
moves in oh and but B SW gets enough of
it one hand tried to just slide
it back raise it above that pad
bris doesn't even go down half down one
leg down right pad still out makes the
save there's the Canadians bench here's
Nikolai eers trying to keep the shootout
going eers moves in and Jake Allen
the [Music] and the Montreal Canadians
Victorious against the winter Pig
Jets well Jake Allen deserves that